[Música]
la Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos
desestimó una petición del expresidente
Donald Trump en la que solicitaba
mantener en secreto sus declaraciones de
impuestos ahora el ex mandatario tendrá
que entregar estos documentos a un
comité del Congreso que lo investiga por
presunta evasión fiscal ampliamos desde
Washington
en Brasil el partido liberal que apoyó
la candidatura del presidente Jair
bolsonaro a las presidenciales de
octubre pidió invalidar los resultados
de las urnas electrónicas más antiguas
usadas durante la jornada el Tribunal
Superior electoral condicionó la
aceptación de la demanda la que también
se han cuestionados los resultados de la
primera vuelta
el tribunal constitucional de Perú
ordenó la anulación del proceso contra
el presidente Pedro Castillo por
presunta traición a la patria por haber
declarado que su país podría facilitar
una salida al mar Para Bolivia la
demanda podía generar la inhabilitación
del mandatario pero la corte aceptó un
recurso de habeas Corpus de la defensa
Tenemos reporte
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornada soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos en Estados Unidos
el expresidente Donald Trump sufrió un
revés luego de que la Corte Suprema le
ordenara que publique sus declaraciones
de impuestos que él quería mantener en
secreto ahora la información estará
disponible para un comité de la cámara
de representantes que investiga una
posible evasión fiscal previamente
conversamos con Cristóbal Vázquez que
nos dio más información
concretamente lo que ocurrió fue que la
Corte Suprema de Justicia máximo órgano
judicial de este país y que además tiene
mayoría conservadora después de que
Donald Trump precisamente haya nombrado
a tres magistrados de corte conservador
pues le negó el recurso de emergencia
que los abogados de Donald Trump estaban
buscando para que Donald Trump no
tuviera que presentarle su declaración
de impuestos a este comité de finanzas
de la cámara de representantes que en
este momento es de mayoría demócrata
entonces así las cosas Pues en la
autoridad de impuestos de Estados Unidos
va a tener que entregar estos documentos
estas declaraciones de renta del ex
presidente Donald Trump en los últimos
años que recordemos el ex presidente
había tratado de tapar desde el 2016
cuando siendo candidato se le pidió que
la publicara Pero él de muchas maneras y
a través de muchas
formas y vías legales trató de esconder
Pues ahora ya legalmente
opción lo demócratas de ver esto lo que
pasa es que el 3 de enero cambia de mano
la cámara de representantes y los
republicanos se espera que pues
suspendan esta petición para que se
publique esta información financiera del
ex presidente vamos a Brasil porque el
partido liberal que apoyó la candidatura
a la reelección del presidente Jair
bolsonaro presentó una acusación ante el
tribunal superior electoral para pedir
que se anulen los resultados de la
segunda vuelta de las presidenciales que
ganó el izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva el documento solicita anular
los votos registrados en unas 350.000
urnas electrónicas que son las más
antiguas utilizadas durante la jornada
argumentando que los resultados son
imposibles de auditar El supremo
condiciono la aceptación de la demanda
que también se presente un requerimiento
sobre la primera vuelta en la que se
utilizaron las mismas urnas esto en un
plazo no mayor a 24 horas según los
determinado por nuestra área técnica
contratada estas inconsistencias no
permiten dar fe del resultado o las
urnas registraron efectivamente el
resultado electoral
vengo a decir que hoy estamos aquí con
una sola intención contribuir al
fortalecimiento de la democracia en
nuestro país
en Perú el tribunal constitucional
ordenó la anulación del proceso que
adelantaba el congreso contra el
presidente Pedro Castillo por presunta
traición a la patria luego de que
afirmara que su país podía facilitar una
salida al mar Para Bolivia previamente
conversamos con Francisco Zacarías
corresponsal en Perú que nos explicó que
argumentó el tribunal para anular el
pedido que ya había sido aprobado por la
subcomisión de acusaciones
constitucionales
les cuento que el tribunal
constitucional de este país declaró
fundada la demanda de habas Corpus
presentada por el presidente Pedro
Castillo porque considera que la
acusación de traición a la patria
formulada por el parlamento peruano
carece de fundamentación objetiva no esa
Correa con los parámetros de
razonabilidad y transgrede el debido
proceso en la sede parlamentaria en
realidad diversos juristas ya venían
criticando este procedimiento del
Congreso peruano porque señalan ellos
que el presidente Pedro Castillo jamás
violó la ley peruana ni tampoco violentó
la Constitución Política de este país al
ofrecer una salida al mar a Para Bolivia
durante una entrevista que brindó a
enero de este año señalan que solamente
fueron declaraciones palabras opiniones
y en ese país opinar no es delito
entonces por eso convalidan la decisión
del tribunal constitucional Pero bueno
qué es lo que viene ahora este esta
sentencia el tribunal constitucional le
arruina los planes
y los opositores del presidente Castillo
en el parlamento porque ahora van a
necesitar recurrir a un proceso de
vacancia presidencial o un impeachment
para tratar de sacarle el cargo al
presidente de castillo y para ellos se
necesitan se necesitan 87 votos que
ahorita no pueden reunirlos Esa es la
situación
en Colombia el programa de Naciones
Unidas para el desarrollo presentó el
capítulo de su informe final dedicado a
analizar la evolución de los últimos 10
años de ese país en materia de
desarrollo humano el acuerdo de paz
entre las extintas FARC y el estado
mejorado Los indicadores pero la
pandemia y la crisis climática se han
convertido en el principal freno de la
evolución Luis Muñoz tiene más detalles
logros importantes en Colombia pero
marcados por la pandemia es la
conclusión del programa de Naciones
Unidas para el desarrollo en su informe
sobre la evolución de la última década
con un claro éxito
es el acuerdo el acuerdo de La Habana el
acuerdo de paz el acuerdo entre el
estado y las FARC de 2016 coincide con
una disminución permanente en la tasa de
homicidios como se observa en la Gráfica
los asesinatos en Colombia entre 2003 y
2011 pasaron de 57,81 a 36,20 por cada
100.000 habitantes con un descenso que
se mantuvo hasta 2021 cuando cayó a un
27,74 sin embargo el informe advierte de
que después del acuerdo de paz ha habido
un incremento en indicadores de
violencia marcado por un fenómeno nuevo
el asesinato de líderes sociales
medioambientales y excombatientes de las
FARC el ámbito de mayor preocupación
para Colombia es el medio ambiente y la
crisis climática
entre el año 2012 y 2020 se han
deforestado más de 1,3 millones de
hectáreas esto es un 71% más respecto a
la década anterior Mientras que el 47%
del país es decir 184 municipios
presentan valores catalogados con riesgo
alto y muy alto en cuanto a la crisis
climática la última década ha sido de
Gran éxito en indicadores sociales como
la reducción en la desigualdad de
ingresos de pobreza monetaria el aumento
de escolaridad y una mayor cobertura
educativa y de acceso a la salud sin
embargo después de la pandemia de Kobe
19 cayó el índice de desarrollo humano
por primera vez en la historia El pib se
contrajo en un 7% el desempleo creció en
5 puntos 3,6 millones de personas
cayeron en pobreza monetaria y 2,8
millones en pobreza monetaria extrema
indicadores que el nuevo gobierno de
izquierda de Gustavo Petro se ha puesto
como objetivo revertir en los próximos
cuatro años
en El Salvador el Ministerio de defensa
informó que se han incautado 12,8
toneladas de diferentes tipos de droga
en lo que va del año las autoridades
señalaron que desde junio de 2019 cuando
una Jeep buqué le asumió la presidencia
la cifra de drogas decomisadas asciende
a 28,4 toneladas el último decomiso se
realizó el pasado 14 de noviembre cuando
un cargamento de más de tres toneladas
de cocaína con un costo de unos 79
millones de dólares fue interceptado en
el Pacífico en una lancha conducida por
tres ciudadanos ecuatorianos
vamos ahora hasta Qatar donde este
miércoles se juega la cuarta jornada del
mundial de fútbol cuatro encuentros
marcan el día todos del grupo e y dos
del grupo F entre las elecciones que se
estrenan están Alemania Bélgica y España
Costa Rica será la representante
latinoamericana de la jornada desde doha
Natalia Ruiz enviada especial de France
24 nos amplía
este miércoles entran en Lisa los grupos
e y f en este mundial de Qatar el grupo
e abrirá y terminará esta jornada
primero con un Marruecos ante Croacia
los subcampeones del mundo que esperan
lograr mucho mejor que en 2018 y luego
vendrán los Diablos Rojos que se
enfrentarán a Canadá No tendrán a lukaku
y se enfrentarán sobre todo a Canadá
este equipo que fue el primero en la
clasificación de la Concacaf en cuanto a
la grupo F serán los excampeones de del
mundo España los que se midan ante los
áticos los costarricenses que lograron
llegar a este mundial tras ganar en la
repesca y el segundo partido de ese
grupo será entre Alemania y Japón los ex
campeones del mundo que esperan lograr
esta vez pasar de la fase de grupos cosa
que no lograron Hace cuatro años toda
una vergüenza para la menshop mientras
que se me dirán A Japón que de hecho en
Rusia lograron su mejor resultado en un
mundial pasar a octavos de final así
llegamos al final de esta emisión
noticias a ustedes Les agradecemos su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que
volvemos en unos momentos
[Música]